the red sox using an opener josh osich
is going to be the starter he's long
been really just a loogie type guy that
left handed one out specialist but he's
going to have to pitch full innings now
in the new rules and he'll pitch a full
first inning tonight 1-1 to rosario hit
on the ground to the right side bobbled
by the second baseman peraza picks it up
fires to first close and safe is the
call mets have the lead off man on on
the error here's pete alonso and he
swings and drives one to center jackie
moving back he has the room just in
front of the track he makes the catch
for the out jeff mcneill will be the
batter he hits it hard off the shin of
debra as rolls towards second base and
third base is unoccupied rosaria being
chased by bogarts and he can't get it
the ball hit off the shin of devers
rolled in front of second base rosario
heads up base winning so third base was
uncovered bull guards chased and took a
dive i thought he got him on the foot
but i could be wrong
oh he got him
and they're gonna call rosario out so
that leaves the mets with two outs
and a runner at first
and they got him picked off to throw to
moreland moreland fires down to bogarts
and they put the tag on the sliding
mcneil who's picked off by osich turns
out to be a pretty good inning for josh
michael walker will make his first start
as a new york met and we'll certainly
hope it goes better than rick porcello's
first start as a met last night and he's
facing andrew benintendi to lead off
there's a bunt third base side walk of
bear hands fires and throws it away
backed up by mcneil who puts a tag
on the runner ben attendee but he had
not turned in towards second so ben
attendee is safe at first and that
should be an infield hit and he gets his
first hit of the year he's been old for
10. here is jd martinez right and better
and there's the cutter swung out and
missed strike three so martinez goes
down on strikes one man away runner at
first rafael devers coming up and he got
him with a change-up so waka using that
signature change to great effect strikes
out martinez endeavors back to back two
men down so here is bogarts and bogarts
lifts it out to right michael conforto
right there waiting for it
and that retires aside so walker works
around the bun single by benin tendi no
score after one at fenway let's get the
lead off man on for the second straight
inning it's their first walk of the game
here's michael conforto off to the best
start of any of the mets he's got a home
run in four career at bats against osich
photo hits a high fly ball deep to right
field back goes verdugo at the wall it's
gone michael conforto with his first
home run of the year and the mets have a
two to nothing lead paul seawall
retrieved that ball in the seats he's
trying to throw it back and then
threaten to throw it back whose team are
you on ball a one out base hit in front
of pete alonso and that is asking for
trouble pete's 1 for 12 so far alonzo
hammers one toward the left field corner
headed for the monster and it's gone a
home run for pete alonso it was a
straight line drive and it just barely
got above the green monster in left
field as pete alonso finally gets that
first home run of 2020 to make it
four-nothing new york and the red sox
with their eight and nine hitters of the
first two men out of the third walka
finds himself in trouble here two on
nobody out as andrew benintendi stands
in and he goes down swinging on the
changeup and waka's got the strikeout
his third of the night for the first
down of the inning now here's jd
martinez chance for two if they hurry
the tag by canelo and he turns the
double play and that retires the side
nicely done by robinson canoe and that
gets waka through the third four nothing
meant admits runners on first and second
now with nobody out is dominic smith
and dom cracks one toward right center
field back in the gap goes for dugo and
that ball's out of here dom smith clubs
a three-run homer the mets have hit home
runs in the last three innings
and the mets have built a 7-0 lead at
fenway here is mitch moreland two down
bases empty moreland with a high deep
drive right field get out way back there
and mitch moreland has done it again
for the second time this season
mitch moreland gets the red sox on the
board graduate third bradley at second
with two down walka try to put a close
to this bottom of the fifth and give
himself a chance to get a win in his
first start as a met and martinez flies
one out to right overcomes conforto
toward the line and that retires the
side they got from michael walker as he
strands two in scoring position at the
fifth brings up
zander bogarts he's flied out and struck
out one one hit high and deep into the
triangle racing turning back on it
looking up it is gone
bogart's into the red sox bullpen
an opposite field homer
and the red sox get one back it is seven
to two match seven red sox four lugo
making it look easy just phase three and
retired them all swung on and hit hard
up the middle on one hop to the
shortstop rosario he's got it throws to
first put it in the books the new york
mets have taken the opener